cool so I'm Matthew clock I'm a program
when the gun nice to meet you nice to
meet you
so the guns between is like a surreal
puzzle adventure game pulled the story
of two best friends trick is in the game
you don't control the characters at all
you should call time to move time back
with a polka solve puzzles okay so with
that time manipulation going on yeah
okay cool cool control is really simple
just let the right moves time x to
attract the things the environment okay
so I'm gonna watch the Attic
- character center
you don't control the car loan
yeah
they're kind of like on the beach
we go
Parliament asked an omission of a test
you know you got you
the unity that booty
let's play something not happening me
what
to be such a medication
ya know Marie love every evening in
Caracas
yeah
no problem as it right now it's time and
emulation
singer planner
[Music]
all the story has two divisions
okay
we have information on these two
characters
yeah salute your best friends reprint
so the start of the game you can see the
return
just like an elephant laughs -
you can see this level of like moving in
boxes like
this is like this very stop
as you go
yeah baby in the first level they that's
where they first mind industrial
they wake up on the beach
we need to love it the goal is to find
to the level
and you're letting a pleasure
it's all the puzzles of the game
let's think they give you a lot think
the tagline way
how you take to the branches
like
yeah
Latin time the significance of the day
the power
I guess it's gonna by going to
interpretation over there like inside
but I guess it's kind of like the
goodbye
I love like it
well
remember just like focus on finishing
the game then against yeah
that's good
[Laughter]
broad
this is like the little jumper character
it's going to jump up taking carry the
lantern for you you can pick up a live
from different license to be your rewind
here Atika said if you could put those
down
okay you got it yeah
the stream
yeah a little bit the blood goes get it
together that reflection
[Music]
the supposed to give away around
with questions - yeah the puzzles get
yeah definitely so in the next couple of
levels - levels off this we saw massing
with time doing some interesting things
but never lipstick under designed to be
like a pretty simple relaxing
1080p
[Music]
it'll look great okay
yes yeah
okay
[Laughter]
once he brings it back
never showing a playstation so if
anyone's coming down to pax a couple
bites
animals
something water
if you keep going forward you're working
out
right
he can he can hit these times I'm gonna
chime this ring flowers over news
now when you rewind you don't lose the
light
all right
there we go the gardens between the one
assisting for ELISA Gonzaga
let's have Carol again
sometime later this year yeah this year
we as forests and hopefully and
hopefully expose an absolute pleasure